it's opening night for a very special
work in Dortmund and the star of the
show is spelled out big the work is
called pop oratorio the subject is
Martin Luther widely considered the
father of the Protestant Reformation
Saturday marked the 498 anniversary of
the clergyman's historic break with the
Catholic Church the project includes a
lay choir with over 3000 people from the
local area it's a nice feeling for a
choir it's not about knowing whether you
can do it but that you can do it you
need the confidence that you can do what
you've been rehearsing
almost 500 years ago Martin Luther
nailed his 95 theses to the castle
church door in Wittenberg but the work
centers on a different event Luther's
summons to appear before the Holy Roman
Emperor informs Hamburg based Musical
star Frank finkles plays Luther
at the hearing in horns Luther was in
essence put on trial for heresy he
survived only thanks to friends in high
places the pop art area was composed by
DJ pug the basement of his studio in
Dusseldorf is adorned with over 50 gold
and platinum discs Falck is one of the
most successful producers on the German
music scene as a broad shaft Sonia
shmeckler this is what the word message
is a bit over the top
we're not the electronic Church from
South Carolina we're not interested in
doing some big Bible show we want to
tell an exciting story about a person we
had an impact on society both here and
around the world
wisely equal toward Islam disorder God's
event for ended
the members of the choir began meeting
for rehearsals several months ago
the libretto was written by Michel
kunsan he's been following the
production every step of the way
including both choir and soloist
rehearsals cuenca has provided the
lyrics for a range of track topping hits
and popular musicals
Boyet event what we wanted to do is to
create an event that isn't fusty and
old-fashioned that isn't classically
traditional one that doesn't put on airs
yeah I'm really popping okay we wanted
to make it an upbeat evening of pop and
rock where the music shows the audience
that these issues are still important to
all of our lives there were two shows on
that first day both to an almost
sold-out crowd of nearly 8,000 my family
up there it's my son singing so it's a
special thrill
it's a great and modern musical but we'd
have preferred historical costumes
very appealing for young people - I like
it
it's good to see Church themes being
presented to a large audience it's
something you don't see often enough
the performers got a standing ovation in
2017 the 500th anniversary of the
beginning of the Reformation the Papa
rhetoric will tour Germany